my mother's of violence a wonderful
violinist still playing in the New York
Philharmonic and and I was more aware of
it I mean it's not that I forget about
it and you know I'll never be able to do
that and it's a very unique situation in
a kind of fantastic wonderful situation
but early in the time I was conducting
the orchestra the first times I was
conducting the earth shot I certainly
was moral aware of the fact that my
mother was sitting over over to my left
now frankly there's so much to think
about there's so much to worry about
there so many elements that I have to
keep in my mind that i would say that
her presence has assumed it's sort of
proper proportion now and we're
somewhere she's there I'm happy she's
there I'm lucky that she's playing
really really well and there are no
issues as far as that goes because I
guess technically I'm her boss and if
there were any sort of issues I would be
the one who would have to deal with it
and you know she's at the top of her
game and that keeps it simple
absolutely yeah she's my mother after
all she will often I mean sometimes it's
silly advice like oh you know I didn't
like those clothes you were you know
whatever but um she you know she she
says you know here it felt a little bit
pushed or if you feel like we could use
a little more time on this this is
really interesting feedback to get in
and because of the hierarchy and because
of the nature of the situation
conductors tend not to get a lot of
feedback from the orchestra which is
probably good because it could become
really messy if everybody in the
orchestra felt that it was okay to give
his or her advice and you know there's
some boundaries that are probably worth
preserving but it's also very useful
because the musicians are smart and they
have a lot of perspective and experience
and you know good advice is always
welcome and you know it happens that my
mother feels comfortable saying things I
mean she basically leaves me to my to my
my work but occasionally she will
definitely say oh you know this was a
little faster you know we need a little
more help with the bead at this point
and it's useful